here at home local businesses
celebrating the holiday as visitors
return to vegas
and restrictions start to loosen up one
of those businesses is project barbecue
that's right next to circa
along fremont street they're celebrating
in a very unique way
our hector mejia caught up with the
owner earlier today
this is our favorite day of the year we
we absolutely
invite everybody down bring your mask
we're going to try to stay social
distance the best we can
we've got green tacos the green hog
extravaganza
and the cheer squad out there too we
absolutely do
so tell us about how excited are you
guys to welcome back people for after
you know so long
well i mean it's been two years so we
we're really excited that we get to do
this this year it's raining gold coins
oh yes absolutely all day long
looks fun well we know this is not the
only spot honoring the march 17th
holiday
we have much more on our website eight
newsnow dot com
whatever your plan is we encourage you
to celebrate
safely